[Music]
[Applause]
she's
tf1
[Music]
600 jazz and salsa matches
no
[Music]
yes like a pig
a size lease
[Music]
that's it
no this ticket
the state
and why not
read and this day
that's what
[Music]
m
we are
[Music]
yes I'm
scared fit and hope month
[Applause]
yes was
[Music]
this
year what is
m
and like
[Music]
m
I
know  what to talk about
[Music]
I'm
yours
come and help us
obliged
fo wasn't it me
on May 10
[Applause]
[Music]
au
m
[Music]
the
no that doesn't
matter
[Music]
college
to them all peace
j
and that
in case
then
[Music]
no no no
[Applause]
[Music]
and so much the better
and every year that's enough
valves is no and two yeses
offered themselves
to me
[Applause]
[  Music]
yeah
on May 6 balance sheet is
free
the and on the east I know
m
[Music]
yes
we are
p
[Music]
but ladies we  is great
sorry
I don't
know I know named
[Music]
and sms months
we are
rich town hall
the hopes
that the mines say years
[Music]
and
you